we're on problem 71 it says what is the
value of x in the triangle below okay so
we could just pull out the Pythagorean
theorem here although you might
recognize that if these two sides are
the same then these two base angles are
going to be the same and if those base
angles are the same then this is a what
if this is 90 so then you have 90
degrees to go between those two angles
so they're gonna have to be 45 because
they're the same right so this is a
45-45-90 triangle and if you haven't
already you'll eventually memorize kind
of how the sides of a 45-45-90 relate to
its hypotenuse but you don't have to
memorize it you can prove it here
sometimes it's just faster on
standardized tests and things like that
so what does the Pythagorean theorem
tells us it tells us that this side
squared that so let's say x squared plus
this side squared plus x squared is
equal to the hypotenuse squared is equal
to 10 squared which is 100 so we get 2 x
squared is equal to 100 x squared is
equal to 50 right dividing both sides by
2 and then what does this turn into so
we can say X is equal to the square root
of 50 let's see is there anything that
we can do here to simplify it at all let
me think
X is equal to the square root of 50 oh
sure 50 is so X is equal to the square
root of 50 is 25 times 2 right so that's
equal to the square root of 25 times the
square root of 2 which is equal to 5
times the square root of 2 choice B
problem 72 what is the value of x in
inches okay so once again we a couple of
problems ago we saw a 30-60-90 triangle
this is another 130 degrees 90 degrees
they have to add up to 180 this one is
equal to 60 degrees and we kind of I did
that big convoluted drawing where I
flipped it in all of that and I think
this is a good time to just memorize the
sides of a 30-60-90 triangle because
that's something that one needs to know
in life it's surprisingly useful
especially once you start taking
standardized tests or do trigonometry so
I'll just give you the general rule
so let me just draw another one right
here so let's say this is my other
30-60-90 triangle all right this is
clearly the hypotenuse up here that's
the hypotenuse this is the 30 I call it
the 30-degree side it's opposite the
30-degree angle or so shortest side so
the general rule is if this side right
here is X then the hypotenuse is going
to be 2x and we saw that in that
previous video and then you can actually
use the Pythagorean theorem here to
solve for this last side you really just
remember eyes that the hypotenuse is
twice the shortest side so in this case
what's the shortest side is opposite the
30-degree side so it's 7 so the
hypotenuse would be twice that which is
14 and you could use the Pythagorean
theorem to figure out X now or you could
just memorize that the the middle side I
guess you could say or the long non
hypotenuse side or the 60-degree side
the OP is the side opposite the
60-degree angle that's equal to the
square root of 3 times the short side
times the short side so in this case X
is the square root of 3 times 7 so X is
equal to 7 times the square root of 3
and don't take my word for it oh well
you could take my word for that this is
double that we prove that in a couple of
videos ago but you could do that by that
Gurren theorem here you could say that 7
squared which is 49 plus x squared is
going to be equal to the hypotenuse
squared 14 squared is what 141 44 4
times 14 is 196 subtract 49 from both
sides you get x squared is equal to
let's see 196 minus 50 would be 141 56 1
150 so it's 157 is that right oh my god
let me show I got it 14 times 14 14
times 14 4 times 4 is 16 56 0 140 right
196 and then if you were subtract 49
from that - 49
this is an 8 this is a 16 we have a 7
sorry 147 now it's good thing I checked
that 147 all right so X is equal to the
square root of 147 147 is 49 times 3 is
equal to the square root of 49 times 3
well that's just equal to the square
root of 49 times the square root of 3
which is equal to 7 root 3 which is what
we got but if it might be easier to just
memorize that the side opposite the
60-degree side is going to be the square
root 3 times the short side and the
short side is going to be 1/2 the
hypotenuse anyway the more practice you
do with those the more it'll make sense
ok a square is circumscribed about a
circle what is the ratio of the circle
to the area of the square so the square
is to confront about the circle so let
me draw the circle in the square so if
that's my circle and then if I want to
draw a square see if I can
nope not that's not what I wanted to do
I wanted to draw a solid square let's
let me see if I could draw it without
pressing the shift key oh well I think
that's close enough so that we know that
the squares on the outside because it's
about the circle its circumscribed about
the circle what is the ratio of the area
of the circle to the area of the square
so let's say that this is the center of
the circle right there this is its
radius let's call that R well what's the
area of the circle of the square going
to be if that's the radius this is also
the radius right so one side of this
square up here is going to be 2 R and so
this side is also going to be 2 R it's a
square all the sides are the same so the
area of the square so they want to know
the ratio of the area of the circle to
the to the area of the square okay so
area of circle over the area of the
square right area circle to the area the
square is equal to the area of the
square is just 2 R times 2r which is
what 4 R squared
four squared that's 2r times to our area
of the circle is just PI R squared you
hopefully you learn the formula area of
the circle it's just area is PI R
squared so write that down PI R squared
divide the numerator in the denominator
by R squared and you're left with PI to
4 and that's choice D problem 74 in the
circle below a B and C D are chords
intersecting at e fair enough
if a e is equal to 5 so this is equal to
5 let me pick another color be e is
equal to 12 B is equal to 12 B e is
equal to 12 what is the value of de BOC
e is equal to 6 C e is equal to 6 what
is the value of de let's call that X now
I'm not going to prove it here just for
saving time but there's a neat property
of chords within a circle that if I have
two chords intersecting a circle it
turns out that the two segments when you
multiply them times each other are
always going to be equal to the same
thing so in this case 5 times 12 let me
write that down so this 5 and this 12 so
the two segments of chord a B so 5 times
12 that's going to be equal to these two
segments multiplied by each other and
I'll do that in a different color these
two segments it's going to be equal to x
times 6 so you get 60 is equal to 6 X
divide both sides by 6 you get X is
equal to 10 and that is choice C and
I'll leave you that might be a fun thing
for you to think about after this video
of why that is maybe you want to play
around with chords and prove to yourself
that that's always the case at least
that it makes intuition for you makes
sense
RB is tangent to us to a circle right RB
is tangent tangent means that it just
touches the outside of the circle right
there only one point and it's actually
perpendicular to the radius at that
point so this is the radius of that
point right the centers at a this is a
radius and it's tangent at point B so
it's perpendicular to the radius at that
point at point B D is the diameter okay
fair enough
well then that's right a is a a is a
center so that's kind of obvious I guess
well yeah the line so it that's obvious
so they want to know what is the measure
of angle C be our C be our C no C be our
so they want to know what this angle is
equal to well I well I kind of did it an
inverted advertently we know that when a
line is tangent to a circle it's
perpendicular to the radius at that
point so this whole angle is 90 degrees
so the angle that we're trying to figure
out let's call that X that's the
complement 225 right X plus 25 is equal
to 90 subtract 25 from both sides X is
equal to 65 degrees 65 and that is
choice B next problem
I'm all out okay I'll see you in the
next video